in the last video on quasars I think I
sparked some interest when I threw out
the idea of the Milky Way galaxy
actually colliding with the Andromeda
galaxy which people think will happen in
three to five billion years and I throw
out in the context of maybe maybe the
supermassive black holes at the core of
the galactic cores of each of those
galaxies will start getting a little bit
more material when that collision
happens and maybe quasars will happen I
don't know
but given the interest in that what I
wanted to do here is kind of an
unconventional thing for the Khan
Academy and actually show a video and
before I play the video I have to give
credit where credit is due this is a
this is a super computer simulation made
at the National Center for
supercomputing applications in NASA and
it's by B Robertson of Caltech and L
Hearn Quist of Harvard University and
what I want you to remember is this is
this is super sped up in time just to
give an idea the amount of time it takes
for a star about as far away as the Sun
to make one orbit around the galactic
core is 250 million years and you're
going to see that this is this is
happening multiple times over the course
of this video so this video is actually
spanning billions of years but when you
actually speed up time like that you'll
see that it really gives you the sense
of the actual dynamics of these
interactions the other thing I want to
talk about before I actually start the
video is to make you realize when we
talk about galaxies colliding it doesn't
mean that the stars are colliding in
fact they're going to be very few stars
that actually collide the probability of
a star star collision is very low and
that's because we learned when we look
to earned about interstellar scale that
there's mostly free space in between
stars the closest star to us is 4.2
light-years away and that's roughly 30
million times the diameter of the Sun so
forever you have a lot more free space
than star space or even solar system
space so let's start up this animation
it's pretty amazing and what you're see
here so these are just the obviously so
one rotation is actually 250 million
years give or take but now you see these
stars right here starting to get
attracted to this core and then they're
actually attracted to that core and then
they're and then some of the stuff in
that core was attracted to those stars
and they get pulled away that was the
first pass of these two galaxies some
stuff is just being thrown
off into intergalactic space and you
might worry maybe that'll happen to the
earth and there's some probability that
it would happen two years but it really
wouldn't affect what happens within
those stars solar systems this is what
happening so slow you wouldn't feel like
some type of acceleration or something
and then this is the second pass so they
passed one pass and once again we're
doing this this is a occurring over
hundreds of millions or billions of
years and then on the second pass they
finally are able to merge and all of
these interactions are just through the
gravity over interstellar or almost you
could call it intergalactic distances
you can see they merge into what could
be called as a milk Amida or maybe then
dramedy way I don't know what whatever
you want to call it but even though
they've merged a lot of the stuff it's
Patil been thrown off into intergalactic
space base but this is a pretty amazing
animation to me i won it's amazing to
think about how this could happen over a
galactic space scales and time scales
but it's also pretty neat how a
supercomputer can do all of the
computations to figure out what every
particle which is really a star or
cluster of stars or group of stars is
actually doing to actually give us a
sense of the actual dynamics here but
this is this is pretty neat this is
pretty neat look at that I mean these
are you know every little dot is whole
groups of stars thousands of stars
potentially